here's video of noted bisexual Canadian
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau here he is
in Latvia lecturing his own troops about
climate change
climate change is having a real
destabilizing and negative impact
with more and more frequent extreme
weather events
at home
as challenging as it is at home
impacts around the world where people
are in more precarious economic and
Geographic situations than we are
that's a new reality that has huge
implications for security around the
world which is one of the reasons why
Canada is stepping up to build the
center of excellence for climate
security
in Montreal that's one of the
announcements we're going to be making
tomorrow at at the NATO Summit
guys Canada is building the center for
excellence for climate security oh my
God Justin Trudeau look at my socks
can you imagine being a Canadian citizen
who uh voluntarily signs up for the
military right and Canada is not known
as a country that's going to send its
troops all over the place and blow up a
whole bunch of stuff or anything like
that then they send yet a Latvia there's
not a lot going on in Latvia you're
stationed in Latvia having a nice
Latvian Orthodox lunch and what are they
going to do to you they send that
ridiculous buffoon to lecture you about
climate change and by the way guys that
will be very connected to the next round
of Wars once they finish up World War
III with this Ukraine thing we will have
climate Wars and God knows what else I
just can't imagine truly like joking
aside like you're you're a member of the
Canadian military they send you you know
half the world away and you have to
listen to that guy talk about how he's
going to set up some conference where
they're going to somehow stop the
climate
from changing as if this guy can do
anything other than lock down his own
people and close their bank accounts
which he's quite good at
[Music]
foreign